transporting the foreign fighters to the border.
These were networks of mercenaries, not ideologues,
who were in the coordination business for profit.
For example, they charged Saudi foreign fighters
substantially more than Libyans, money that would have
otherwise gone to al Qaeda.
Perhaps the adversary would disrupt their own network
if they knew they cheating would-be jihadists.
In January, 2010, a devastating 7.0 earthquake struck Haiti,
third deadliest earthquake of all time, left one million people,
10 percent of the population, homeless.
One seemingly small aspect of the overall relief effort
became increasingly important as the delivery of food
and water started rolling.
January and February are the dry months in Haiti,
yet many of the camps had developed standing water.
The only institution with detailed knowledge of Haiti's
floodplains had been leveled
in the earthquake, leadership inside.
So the question is, which camps are at risk,
how many people are in these camps, what's the
timeline for flooding, and given very limited resources
and infrastructure, how do we prioritize the relocation?
The data was incredibly disparate. The U.S. Army had
detailed knowledge for only a small section of the country.
There was data online from a 2006 environmental risk
conference, other geospatial data, none of it integrated.
The human goal here was to identify camps for relocation
based on priority need.
The computer had to integrate a vast amount of geospacial
information, social media data and relief organization
information to answer this question.
By implementing a superior process, what was otherwise
a task for 40 people over three months became
a simple job for three people in 40 hours,
all victories for human-computer symbiosis.
We're more than 50 years into Licklider's vision
for the future, and the data suggests that we should be
quite excited about tackling this century's hardest problems,
man and machine in cooperation together.
Thank you. (Applause)
(Applause)